comment ils vont là et puisque de
propagation du virus dans la population
sont très faibles
faux bon ben voilà on est toujours à la
maison franchement c'est devenu la
routine
j'ai l'impression d'être devenu un
automate tous les jours fait exactement
les mêmes actions je suis toujours
habillé pareil je sais même plus quel
jour on est chaque jour est une
répétition de répétition plus
l'impression d'être dans un jour sans
fin quant à fait les courses tu rentres
chez toi tu te prends pour dexter
alors ça me fait bien rire les gens sans
enfant qui se plaignent du confinement
sur les réseaux aujourd'hui j'ai fait la
grasse mat
j'ai regardé une série je l'habille
watch et je la paye pas en trois heures
à gré de films gfr live un stade une
heure à votre héros
le copil m'ennuie trop dur alors que
quand tes parents daste l'action c'est
garder ton enfant chaque seconde
alors au début du confinement tu prend
des nouvelle de tes proches sais tu les
appelles pour savoir s'ils sont en bonne
santé et tout puis après tu prends des
nouvelles des gens que tu connais un
petit peu moins bien et au bout de six
semaines
tu appelles les gens dont tu t'en vas un
peu les couilles à l'eau aux mains nues
ouais écoute la pandémie a commencé à 6
semaines là toi ça va santé dans ce que
je m'inquiétais de ouf là je me disais
manu depuis six semaines
comment il va quoi il pas plus épais de
coiffeur on a tous les cheveux qu'ils
poussent enfin bon les fausses blondes
et les faux blond vous êtes tous des
masques et il ya pas mal de gens qui
essayent de se couper les cheveux
eux-mêmes et franchement pas ça se voit
alors certains disent que le confinement
permet de se recentrer sur soi même
alors ça c'est bien si à la base c'est
une belle personne parce que si à la
base c'était un gros connard sais pas où
c'est dingue ce que la france est quand
même un pays puissant tu vois et on n'a
pas de masque en papier au dernier
défilé du 14 juillet on avait des tanks
des avions de chasse et visa pata dans
les airs à la place n'aurait pas pu
avoir des camions de masques en papier
non non ça me coûte viola je me calmer
alors j'ai vu qu'il y avait des trafics
de faux masquer des usines clandestines
où ils construisent des masques dans des
parfaites conditions d'hygiène ça traîne
par terre on marche dessus plus rien à
[ __ ] les gars on a fabriqué un million
de masques pour vous par contre seuls
coronavirus 1 le das la peste ffp2 les
mecs
jamais j'aurais cru un jour connaître
les masques ffp2 alors l'enseigne
décathlon a gracieusement offert ses
stocks de masques de plongée en fait aux
pros de la santé conseille hyper
généreux et solidaire comme action c'est
vraiment trop bien mais j'avoue c'est un
peu space quand même imagine tu à
l'hôpital al coronavirus était hyper mal
et là tu vois arriver ton médecin
tut tut tut tut alors petit bilan santé
c'est pas mal je pense qu'on pourrait
sortir d'ici deux-trois jours monsieur
perez
finalement jean joël parviendra à
vaincre la couronne à virus
par contre il moral et suite au
traumatisme et d'une crise cardiaque
les médias pour eux c'est chaud ils sont
vraiment en boucle sur l'épidémie il
répète sans cesse les mêmes choses et
parfois ils doivent meublé tellement ils
ont pu rien à dire un docteur bernard
pensez vous que le coronavirus j'ai plus
d'un spi là je sais plus j'ai posé
toutes les questions possibles je fait
un freestyle intense qu'on vit est
tellement ouf que je les vois mal parler
d'autre chose et aujourd'hui
malheureusement nous déplorons près de
556 cas de décès supplémentaires en
italie
le cerf-volant va-t-il redevenir à la
mode cet été sur les plages
c'est la question que se sont posés à
éric et jean michel alors les le débat
pour ou contre la chloroquine c'est
hyper pointus comme sujet en restait pas
médecin je vois pas comment tu peux
avoir un avis là dessus
pourtant il ya des gens qui s'invente un
avis scientifique alors qu'ils avaient 5
de moyenne en svt
moi je suis complètement d'accord avec
ce que dit didier raoult parce que déjà
il a un bon style a tué en dira un peu
renault et moi j'aime bien c'est sont à
la base et puis en troisième j'ai déjà
d'essayer une grenouille donc ferme ta
gueule c'est parce que c'est un bug ball
z moi le seul truc scientifique que je
fais c'est que tous les matins je
regarde la cour de contamination dans le
monde en espérant qu'elles baissent pour
pouvoir dire car j'ai découvert un truc
la courbe baisse
le monde entier est impacté par le
confinement c'est dingue mini point
positif les animaux ont davantage
d'espacé la nature reprend le dessus et
aussi moins de pollution due à moins
d'activités humaines par contre il ya
une augmentation des violences
conjugales
c'est à dire qu'il ya des énormes con
qui se disent quand même ah [ __ ] je me
fais chier
bon allez j'ai pas de moteur pure race
de l'univers bon bah du coup cette année
le bac est bradée c'est le contrôle
continu qui compte en fait donc les
terminales qui compte se mettre à bosser
en fin de l'année et ballon dans l'ue et
ceux qui vont la voir le bac bas
félicitations ce troc ou là par contre
bon courage pour vos futurs entretiens
votre bac vous l'avez eue en quelle
année
alors j'ai eu mon bac en 2000 pardon
j'ai pas compris quand j'ai eu en 2009
alors j'entends tout le monde dira que
ce confinement c'est l'occasion de faire
des choses qu'on n'aurait pas eu le
temps de faire en temps normal des
choses constructives s'instruire réviser
le code faire des papiers administratifs
et finalement on fait plutôt caisse plus
que 800 pièces alors tout le monde parle
de ce qui fera le premier jour on sera
plus en confinement déjà calmez-vous on
va pas tous allés faire la teuf direct
sur les chansons on va tous attrapé le
côté de 19 en une heure non ça va être
progressif et je pense qu'on rêve tous
de se faire un petit resto en terrasse
enfin dix restaurants là on n'est pas
malin
alors moi je vais vous prendre du
pangolin saignant alors j'ai testé le
fameux what apéro de concept de boire
décolleté potes en conf call quoi bon
déjà tu as toujours un pote à la
cambrousse qui à nos réseaux efficaces
l'ambiance et c'est cool mais tu
raccroches qui est juste bourré tout
seul chez toi ben ouais ouais y'a pas
mal de vidéos qui circulent de gens qui
rappelle qu'il faut rester chez soi
c'est normal ne sortez pas rester chez
vous il ya aussi les stars américaines
qu'ils l'ont fait ils ont l'air hyper
serein et convaincu qu'il faut rester à
la maison
on n'a pas tous la même maison les amis
faites comme moi restez chez vous j'ai
pas fait de la vitrine du jacuzzi du
quad
c pas compliqué quand même
je vise wang n est pas moi ce
confinement c'est mon premier événement
mondial même si c'est un drame un pays
où la conquête de l'ouest le premier
homme sur la lune
je suis du mur de berlin moi je pourrais
dire vous savez les enfants moi j'ai
connu mon salon mais pendant une longue
période
bon j'annonce dans le quelques jours
j'ai fêté mon anniversaire en trois ans
bientôt la mort quand je ne marque pas
te pas de soirée pas de cadeaux génial
par contre il sera vrai on m'a déjà
envoyé un gâteau d'anniversaire
on va dire au goût du jour jeunes 20
niveaux
en fait
et oui merci d'être venus si nombreux
pièce six mois gâcher l'ambiance
maintenant je vais goûter pour vos yeux
ébahis et franchement le goût ne
correspond pas à la merci avant de finir
la vidéo j'ai indiqué à vous dire on
passe bientôt la barre des 12 millions
d'abonnés sur ma chaîne youtube
c'est un truc de ouf merci à tous du
fond du coeur en plus ça tombe pile poil
pour mon anniversaire bon je pense que
c'est pas fait exprès d'autre part mais
ça me fait quand même très plaisir c'est
trop cool dont le message pour les pas
abonné prenez votre doigt mettez du gel
hydro alcoolique ou un gant ou ce que
vous voulez et abonnez vous à ma chaîne
youtube juste ici ce sera mon petit
cadeau de votre part à très bientôt et
surtout restez chez vous ciao go to 12
millions
[Musique]